okay I think we've made some real
progress today I think that miss
Hathaway talking about the benefits of
winning her Oscar shows us all how we
can move on from not starring at our own
Catwoman movie oh please miss Piper
disagrees yes miss Pfeiffer disagrees
they talked about making a Catwoman
movie for years and I was supposed to
play the part but they waited too long
and the fan base died down resulting in
that abomination with Halle Berry Shh
you know we never mentioned she must not
be much but aren't you technically
mentioning her it doesn't matter
Piper's role should've been my role to
begin with yes Sonia we all remember how
you ambushed Tim Burton dressed as
Catwoman in order to force him to put
you in the role that's not community
writing she really did that folks still
isn't matter
Barry stole the role from all of us and
she ruined it yes it was the first time
a Catwoman had been given the leading
role and she boxed it up forever yes and
she has never paid for her actions now
now ladies let's stay focused okay
Eartha Kitt I believe last week we were
discussing how you felt like a man
trapped in a cat woman's body
no I agree with them we should keep our
focus on the pussy bitch who stole my
chances to shine if it wasn't for her
one of us could be the definitive cat
why aren't you dead KitKat is right it's
time for retaliation we can't just sit
here all day and listen to this half-wit
psychic analysis psycho what did you
need to take action
get our leading role burly arse unite
ladies ladies is getting out of hand now
the cat one movie is so despised that no
one would ever write that character in a
leading role
okay I doubt you could even get the lead
in the Catwoman review that what the
Catwoman review the one coming out this
week bye
[Music]
[Applause]
hello I'm in the style guy remember it
so you don't have to when the movie
Batman Returns came out people mostly
have one reaction but how was that but
they also had another reaction Catwoman
was pretty cool
and thus a movie based on the antihero
was in development for ever Tim Burton
went back and forth on the project
Mitchell Pfeiffer went back and forth on
the project
scripts were rewritten and retooled
until it finally reached the perfection
that only years and years of development
can give us oh just look at the costume
of our main carry god let's just get
this over with
[Music]
this film that only tops a lot of worst
comic book films of all time list but it
also taught a lot of worst films of all
time period lists and you can definitely
see why it is a special kind of bad but
kind of bad that the main characters
from the producers were put together as
an intentional flop to cash in on some
sort of money scheme
yeah I'd say let's review it but really
this is more like a study a study in
asking the questions how why and no
those are enough let's go ahead and
study the epic failure that is Catwoman
it all started on the day that I died we
open with our main character deceased
obviously trying to symbolise the movies
ability of being dead on arrival the day
that I died was also
day I started talking with bow of course
get to that later as we see the evil
corporation our main character works for
makeup but they're trying to hide that
better as the husband and wife owners of
the company the wife played by Sharon
Stone are stepping down from being at
spokespeople because they just fucking
look evil it has been a magnificent 15
years but we have decided to choose a
new face to represent beauty exactly
okay quick word of advice to anyone
joining a large corporation if your boss
is laughs like this or how about if your
performance creates the unforgivable sin
of making Rupert Everett look so this
isn't even close I know I can fix it I
do not reward incompetence I have no
idea why I expected your art to show
better taste than your wardrobe you
totally put me off my dick in caviar
party I bet you didn't even know we sell
those did you but she's just too timid
to fight back for herself as our main
character named patience yes our kind
quiet innocent is named patience the
same as maybe these characters meanie
broody or able still manages to get to
his pity as he allows her to turn in the
project tomorrow by midnight but that's
pretty tough seeing how she can't even
tell those hardcore parties with pink
lightbulbs to keep their music down
you'd better pray this isn't creating
contrast for later it's also difficult
when other people's pets like do and
possibly place themselves in dangerous
situations so that others would try to
save them instead of doing something
sensible like only the fire department
[Music]
maybe I can help I know you read the
reviews to the call I'd be depressed too
so the cop saves her but fine she's in a
hurry to return to her everyday mundane
job so every day that this guy is in the
exact same spot as before he's trailing
his desk but the cop manages to find her
and returns her wallet
Tom God that is such a good name Tom
Malone rhymes with Cohn phone boom not
that rhymes are they important just let
me know how he if you want me to be more
awkward or not as attractive as you is
this yours
it's nice thanks
yeah it kind of reminds me of early
should go elegant but whimsical you know
not enough cops use the word elegant and
whimsical I like this new product bit
more bullets meetings all right man I'm
gonna take down this drug lord the
old-fashioned way elegant and whimsical
Peterson I want you to especially be
enchanted and pleasant you've got it sir
I'm gonna break into this bastards home
kick down his door and introduce them to
a world of wonder and marry them now
ready your Boas
tradition of the old Dutch masters I'm
impressed
don't be I noticed all the art in your
apartment so I google it at the office
oh well that's alarmingly creepy I
wanted to apologize to you about the
small
thinking that you were a jumper it's
open I could make it up to you by taking
me to coffee so he apologizes to her for
saving her alive and vosen fights are
out on a date to make up for it
faster wear that leather outfit that's
not your favorite remember I will never
ever ever wear yo I hope this is
creating more contrast because if it
isn't that line will be awkward and
totally pointless but if it is Oh what
am noxious nineties edit later we see
that our messenger to drop off her
design has cancelled so she has to drop
it off at obvious evil headquarters
herself I don't care that the FDA never
saw that the headaches and the nausea
and the fainting spells is it me or is
the editing in this movie out of control
when it has nothing to cut to it will
literally cut to itself I don't care how
short your audience's attention span is
only cut when you have something to cut
tomb it's like a boxer who has nobody to
fight so he just hits himself but she
stumbles across the plan of karela Jane
Lynch whose new makeup line will start
damaging the skin if it's not
continually applied she tries to escape
through the sewers but luckily the
henchmen who doesn't work there know the
exact button to push in order to flush
her out
so she falls into the river yet somehow
ends up on some rocks far away from the
river the water just wrap her where we
see the embarrassingly bad animation
left over from Puss in Boots comes in
and quite literally breathes new life
into her I'm not even making that up
it literally breathes new life into her
[Music]
I suddenly have a need to incorporate
horrible cat jokes into my life oh and
I'm not kidding everything she does the
following day is related to some kind of
bad cat humor she sleeps on a shelf
lands on all fours kisses at dogs eat
several cans of tuna and I shit you not
this is a real scene of what happens
when someone gives her catnip come on
this is a third graders idea of what
Catwoman should be not a the writers and
directors no I take it back third
graders read comics but so even they
would have a better understanding what
makes a better Catwoman than you Julie
Newmar would be telling you to calm down
crazy cat ladies will be calling you
crazy cat lady is this really like your
best foot forward years and years of
rewrites and fine-tuning and this is
honestly what you've come up with we
have even got to the dumbest costume yet
already I'm embarrassed for you I'm
embarrassed to look at you it's like
that kid that joins the football team
he's always like that big way show your
support anyway but it turns out you
shouldn't have because he's in the
hospital with five fractured ribs and
he's like why did you support me why'd
you show your support it's like I don't
know I saw a movie where a woman sniff
catnip and it fucked me up I mean really
who would take being a cat woman this
ridiculously serious cap women unite
we will find this nostalgia critic and
force him to have us star in his review
you know ladies I really don't think
this is helpful to that healing process
oh but we have such plans for you yes in
a few moments
once we conveniently that door will open
to reveal the ferocious killer tiger
burping you limb from limb leaving only
hassle of both thus conclude our death
trap that ties into our villainous
psychic lady is we have a critic to
visit
[Music]
how will the counselor get out of this
one will he be the main course for our
ferocious feline will he be ripped to
shreds and left for Tiger chow will his
body be not until the narcan no no or
will he be next week's kitty litter will
tiger digestion be his new iPod playlist
will he have to spend the rest of his
life as a kitty kebab can the counselors
van being part of a great balanced
breakfast he is there any escape from
his delicious decadent to doom tune in
tomorrow same bat-time same
[Music]
you
so only enough patients have no memory
of being drowned which is never really
explained but after this scene you could
say she's a porcupine and I wouldn't
question it but she does remember that
she forgot her date with her cop friend
and leaves an apology coffee's her life
also seems to have a little bit more
bite
[Applause]
[Music]
I think someone's cooking up some
contrast pay
[Music]
but the contrast doesn't stop there she
gets on that leather outfit she said she
would never put on and starts living up
to her cat burglar name by stealing
stuff but it seems she now has a split
personality as in the morning she does
remember stealing them and actually
returns it with the word sorry written
on it she finally wants to know what the
hell is going on so she would trans the
cat named midnight to its owner and ask
what the hell is going on
you wrote this I was a professor for 20
years but God is fast the miles are
sacred to past they're her messengers oh
and here's a fun game bet yourself ten
dollars that you can listen to this
explanation of who she is without
cracking a smile you follow your own
desires this is both a blessing and a
curse
you are a cat woman incredibly
heightened so I'm not patient sitting on
you are patience and you are Catwoman
you just lost $10 dinger so she shows
all the photoshopped pictures of history
she says that she has been given a gift
that's been passed on through the ages
and that she has tried to prove this
theory as a professor in the past but
nobody has ever believed her
why may I like a dummy answer what was
the reasoning again may I like a dummy
oh okay
look lady um I'm not gonna act like
there isn't some double standard
bullshit going on in the world women
getting paid less than men that's
bullshit
men sleeping around with women being
called a player but woman sleeps around
with men she's called a slut that's
bullshit but when you go around with
your theories that there are effect cat
women who exist today and have existed
years in the past because the spirits of
the Egyptian gods are in these little
tiny felines going around who breathed
on dead women bringing them back to life
is sort of Catwoman zombie if you will
who now exists and fight crime
even to the
day why do you think nobody believed you
again maiya like a dummy is wrong it's
cuz you're fuckin crazy
mail academia suck my sexist women
bashing chauvinistic stripper watching
porn loving overly bangs deck if this
movies all Ruben or power help him in
the next scene she's dressed like a
poster at 13 year old boy when hanging
over his bed and jerk off - yeah look at
that face it looks even dumber close-up
doesn't it I can't tell you how it looks
on her far away because I never see it
on her far away instead they place it on
her CGI puppet which makes me keep
checking the TV to make sure I had to
put on a rewrite on a fucking reboot
someone needs to show these idiots how
Catwoman is really done hello we're just
giving you a fair warning then you
better watch your back and keep an eye
out around every corner because a
fearsome band of Sharptooth okay guess
I'm not gonna throw any caution to the
wind here Oh
[Music]
he opened it I can't believe he just
opened it cats out of the bag critic we
need a row we can sink our teeth in key
and you have the power of Victor Potts
yeah it's really good fun what the hell
is going on here what do you want
we're here to star and your captain in
review so we can show up that cow horse
Halle Berry forget it you're not
stealing this review from me very well
you force us to take action get ready to
be declawed
aha you fallen from the Catwoman's Blue
Raiders weakness fetish fuel come on
ladies let's finally put these things to
some good use oh come on what are you
honestly gonna do with those pointless
thing
[Music]
triplane to the Cattleman's duality it
often wins the critical phrase hey you
seem very to people ish
are you kidding I am so psychologically
tortured what do you mean I'm the one
who's constantly switching sides hey I
am extremely complement oh please you
never even got a chance to be in the
role my dreams were crushed in the first
third of screen time
oh yeah well can you sing about your
dreams like this
I dreamed a dream in time gone by well
that can't fights going on outside let's
see the real catastrophe that's going on
here we see Kent woman goes inside a
club thinking she can find the answers
of who tried to kill her what can I do
for you I'm a cat she locates one of the
thugs that try to kill her that night
and tries to get some info out of him
she was a nice girl why
oh wait gee let me try and guess what
the next line is a dog ate your biscuit
can't catch it no yeah yeah that seemed
much more logical so he tells her about
the secret headquarters she goes there
and then leaves odd but wait a second
our cop friend might be on the lead
about who stole and returned those
jewels from the other night
oh there are similarities shape of the S
or stroke of the arse you took into a
handwriting expert look at them wait
Charles with a fucking blindfold I could
tell it what's that same person okay
don't let this get in the way of your
date we're a carousel brakes and she
uses all her flips and kicks to save a
little kid from falling oh wait a minute
could this and the handwriting point to
her possibly being the culprit well I'm
not sure how you did it but I'm
impressed yes not no clearly he needs to
see her do it like this encounter at
circus de Seussical where she's trying
to get more answers when our cop friend
comes across the Catwoman who's the same
height same skin colour exact same voice
and yet really fucking miraculously
still can't tell who it is
yeah look at him trying to take off that
mask oh you'll figure it out someday Oh
Julie she got away oh well better luck
next time I'm off on a date with my
cat-like girlfriend it's good to get
away from that criminal I'm chasing and
being hooked up with a completely
different person who hates the rain like
a cat eats sushi like a cat cheetah
makes purring sounds while having sex
with you because guess what you fucking
moron she's a goddamn cat can you just
promise me that there's a little blonde
haired nice going around actually
solving the crime for him it would be
any more far-fetched than the rest of
this movie and by God I just have to
have some hope in humanity
party ladies put your kitty pryde into
it
wait I have a better idea Oh
[Music]
that's how to give a dog a bone
huh that was weird
and that's it Catwoman can never resist
a romantic dance sequence
[Music]
anyway Sharon Stone's evil plan is
revealed which is the exact same people
planned in the first 10 minutes
nothing's changed yet we spent an hour
and a half trying to reveal it and she
Frank's Catwoman for the murder of her
husband but Inspector Clouseau finally
figures out it was her the whole time
how well through his brilliant deductive
reasoning and high-tech CSI canta tree
they took the lipstick mark that was
left on his cheek during the fight
sequence and compared it with the
lipstick mark she left on a glass when
they were dating and the DNA and pattern
decoder matched them up perfectly
thus deducing that they are in fact the
same person wow you made that so much
more complicated than it needed to be
hey genius don't tell anyone but I have
a sneaking suspicion that one of these
guys is dealing burgers I haven't
figured out which but she won't find the
culprit so even though she's thrown in
jail she slips through the bars
why do you remind me to hit something
later and makes her way to Sharon
Stone's hideout where she tries to stop
her evil makeup from taking over the
world and you know saying that out loud
makes me realize just how fucking sexist
this empowering women movie sounds mayil
academia get this because she's used the
makeup for so long and makes her skin
indestructible I can't be hurt be lean
stop using it and your face
disintegrates and if you keep using it
skin
living Marvel so wait she's created this
makeup where the more you use it the
more powerful you become and all you had
to do is keep using it to make you
stronger I'm sorry what's the downside
to this Oh
people will rot if you stop using it
well okay keep fucking using it where's
the problem
where are you marketing this in
cosmetics you should be marketing this
to the military male like a dummy oh oh
[Music]
I guess the problem is she's a fucking
liar
the makeup is clearly not indestructible
as it apparently starts coming off oh
[Music]
and apparently indestructible doesn't
also include falling off a building yeah
that's the barely it's kryptonite to
kind of false advertising but whatever
can't woman is proven innocent but fine
she can't stay with her boyfriend
because last ten minutes of spider-man
explanation and I cry for anyone who
didn't get an immediate refund before
the credits started rolling
[Music]
you dance so well yes and since I'm so
complex it feels like I'm dancing with
more than one person actually a little
less than before what am i doing hi you
know I'm not sure if you're aware of the
Internet's policy on boobs you see just
the mere appearance of them even if
they're covered up guarantees a few
count of TT proportions we would be more
than happy to continue exploiting our
boobage once you give us an opinion if
that god-awful Halle Berry don't want
her performance that's easy enough I
think she's fine what I mean it's by no
means good but let's face it there's
nothing any actress could bring to it to
make it work I mean when the script
calls for you to rub catnip on your face
how well can you seriously portray that
it's over-the-top and goofy but I think
that just adds to the insanity that the
film has already gotten across so in all
fairness I see no reason to fall or out
for it
wouldn't you agree is my male academia
showing bullets all of you I mean
haven't you ever put together that maybe
not being in this movie is the best
thing that could ever happen to you
I mean this film is beyond bad like
head-scratching Lee how on earth could
anybody take any sentence in this
seriously bad it's a Marvel it can
barely be put into words nothing in any
realm of reality could possibly save it
from the bad writing and directing that
consumed every frame of this picture
yeah it is that bad and you want to be a
part of that
you don't even know what you're
suffering from do you you are suffering
from cat women raging against Halle
Berry syndrome that's right you all have
crabs so that explains that itchy
feeling inside it's alright a lot of
women who have gone through what you've
gone through have it and it's nothing to
be ashamed of who you have to do is find
a way to live with it and continue to
bring joy to people but how can four
attractive women dress like this bring
joy to people on the Internet there's
definitely a way
I am so fluffy yep the only thing that
desire gets more views than porn is
Kathy Halle Berry and if somebody didn't
like my movie
if you should come across Halle Berry
you are doomed course she clearly has no
idea what makes a real cowboy
[Music]
[Applause]
you
maiya lakatamia
[Music]
I'm Anne Hathaway and I have crabs
I'm Sean Young and I of crabs I'm Eartha
Kitt and I have cramps
I'm Michelle Pfeiffer and I have crabs
I'm just Arriba and I have crabs
really you have Catwoman raging against
Halle Berry syndrome Oh God
[Applause]